I date younger men predominately men in
their 20s and when I date younger men I
have sex with younger men and when I
have sex with younger men I encounter
very directly and personally the real
ramifications of the creeping ubiquity
of hardcore pornography in our culture
so in an era where hardcore porn is more
freely and widely available on the
Internet than ever before and where kids
are therefore able to access it at a
younger and younger age than ever before
there is an entire generation growing up
that believes that what you see in
hardcore pornography is the way that you
have sex and this is particularly
exacerbated because we live in a
puritanical double-standards culture
where people believe that a teen
abstinence campaign will actually work
where parents are too embarrassed to
have conversations about sex with their
children and where educational
institutions are terrified of being
politically incorrect if they pick up
those conversations and so it's not
surprising that hardcore pornography de
facto has become sex education now as a
mature experienced confident older woman
when I encounter this I have no problem
realizing that a certain amount of
re-education rehabilitation and
reorientation has to take place
anybody who is offended by sexually
explicit language please cover their
ears now and I will raise my hand where
you can uncover them so I have no
problem responding as I have regularly
had to actually know thank you very much
I've much rather you did not come on my
face
my concern is both with the young guy
who believes because hardcore
pornography has taught him but my
concern is particularly with the young
girl whose boyfriend wants to come in
her face
she does not want him to come in her
face but hardcore porn has taught her
that all men love coming are women's
faces all women love having their faces
come on and therefore she must let him
come on her face and she must pretend to
like it so so I am launching at Ted
today I am unveiling make love not porn
calm this is a website that hosts the
midst of hardcore porn and balances them
with the reality and it's important to
say by the way that this is absolutely
not about judgement this is not about
good and bad sex is the area of human
experience that embraces the vastest
possible range of proclivities this is
also not anti porn I'm a fan of hardcore
porn I watch it readily myself although
my overriding criteria when selecting it
has to be to find something that does
not resemble overly open heart surgery
but because the porn industry is driven
by men funded by men managed by men
directed by men and targeted at men porn
tends to present one world view porn
says this is the way it is and what I
want to say is not necessarily so please
go to make love not porn calm I want to
ask the Ted audience to do two things
be aware this is an issue because I
would never have realized that if I have
not encountered it myself and please
visit the website please see what you
think
um comment um and please pass it on
please send the link to anybody you
think would be interested and use it to
start a dialogue use it to reframe use
it to reframe an open healthy
conversation around sex in order to help
and facilitate open healthy and better
sexual relationships thank you very much
you